now live welcome back to the Leia hail
plan show guys I'm going to be reacting
to this interview from Andrew Tate which
has just dropped so it's his first
interview since he's been out of jail
with the BBC the way I'm doing this I've
never done it before so you can let me
know in the chat now if you can see the
screen if it's all good and then we'll
kick us off so there we go okay I have I
just had a notification come through
confirming that it is live all right
cool I can see that you all are watching
this is amazing now before I do my
reaction please don't forget to hit the
like button and subscribe so you can
never miss any of these reaction videos
okay all right actually I always have my
brother in the room with me good so I'm
going to ask Gideon I'm changing the
screen can you still see this is it
working you need to check on YouTube can
everyone still see the screen the
problem is there's a delay there's a
delay on my phone oh there's a delay
yeah look you're about to say oh I'm
about to say we'll just check now it's
about to do the switch right now is it
happening is it working oh no no you
can't see look that's me there no we
can't see it you can't see it no oh for
God's sake if you can't see it why can't
you see it I'm having technical issues
oh you can't see it at all that's no we
can't see the screen
oh wow thank you sharing
how do I do this
full screen layout what about now what
about now
can you see it now hold on is it working
now well people we wish okay let me know
let me know in the comments if you can
see I'm trying to do a double share
screen that's essentially what's
happening right now oh yeah yeah we can
see it we can see it but you can't see
me no no uh but we can't see you now how
do you solo layout how do you do double
layer but you can't see technical issues
see I told you guys I had technical
issues we wanted to do we wanted to do
this live but no we can't see you now
oh yeah look it doesn't work okay should
I just do it like this what do you think
I should do
cancel no I mean we're live now but I
don't know how to do that so no way okay
does anybody know I'm using stream yard
does anybody know how to do two at once
do two screens at once what if I stop
playing the video can you hear it yeah
play the video see what happens and also
because there's a great deal of concern
about the things you say
and the impacts that they have on young
people on women I don't think about you
but does it come through does it sound
comfortable yeah
okay the sound comes through sound comes
through but we can't see you I don't
know how to do dual screens you guys
know how to do dual screens this is
crazy okay present it sounds
use the other Grid in stream yard add
Source webcam
sure you had it Split Second
yard
this is crazy sounds fine if you can't
interrupting yeah I know
yeah I know present slides stop sharing
how do I add both of us at the same time
[Music]
I don't know how to do this oh maybe if
I someone goes Shalom Gideon okay I know
wait shalom
this is impossible
maybe if I move this forward free top G
I'm surprised I did an interview
wait hold on
how about now what's happening now
what's happening no you can't see it
you're not on it should work now
you know
what's happening
it should work now oh wow it's still not
working this is crazy wait what if I do
this
I've done solo layouts does that work
oh wait what if I do oh no no we're back
on us now
I don't know how to do this move layer
forward what about now
what about now
oh it's a good thing I did a test
otherwise we would have been continuing
this
what about that
oh it's a good thing I did a test
otherwise all right we I can just start
reviewing this but I'm not sure how full
screen layout
why can't I do why can't I do double
screen no it's still on oh I'm not sure
I know how to do it I know how to do it
give me one sec
I know how to do it
I know exactly how to do it oh my God oh
my God oh my God I know I know how to do
it ready are you ready are you ready are
you ready
are you ready did it work
s wait wait wait oh yeah yeah it's
working you're up it's better it gets
better it gets better wait
yes we did it we did it we did it we're
out is it good do you think that's good
enough is that good is everyone happy
make you bigger but I have to re-edit it
to make me bigger I'm not I have to
re-edit it I just all right I created
like um I've created like a what's it
called uh oh I'm lost for words now guys
oh
template I created attendance created a
template okay cool all right who's ready
how many viewers do we have okay we have
a pile of viewers that's great
we're up guys
look it looks beautiful all right check
it out okay look we're not twitch
streamers we're not streamers okay we're
just like normal YouTubers I just I just
saw that Andrew did this this interview
and I was like oh I better review it and
then this happened so there you go all
right someone says Craft on I will thank
you look I can I can add I can add like
this
also guys I'm gonna kick this off now
um I'm really excited thanks for hanging
in there for us we're going to be
shouting out all the super chats you see
how I can like throw people up like this
oh thank you so much you see
like this all right so we're going to be
doing shout outs to all the soup chats
so send those through and we'll kick
this off look it looks great it's
working yeah we're gonna mute the phone
we'll mute the phone all right okay
who's ready I've not watched this before
I feel like we got there so let's give
this a go again keep promising some
water a little bit of stress after that
a little bit stressed
all right
let's have some water before we go live
all right thanks
yes hair and makeup on set water's good
okay let's go and action okay guys
imagine none of that happens I can't
believe we got that I'm so proud of
myself
you know you know the problem was I
didn't click save on the template that
was the problem
all right let's do this okay
so I'm switching screens if you tell me
that you can still see it tell me that
you can still see it I'm currently full
screen on
um actually it's fine I know that I know
how to do this all right let's click
play
rape
why is it from the very beginning
all right team let's do this
okay that was so stressful
Leia you're the best
I don't feel like it you know that was
pretty stressful
yeah you agree to do an interview with
the BBC today yep the material is going
to be published on television on radio
online perfect
we are doing an interview with you
because your face is very serious
trafficking yeah and also because
there's a great deal of concern about
the things you say
and the impact that they have on young
people on women I don't think
I can't turn any louder is it okay as
loud as it is is that okay can everyone
hear it because I can't turn any louder
and thank you thank you for uh
for admiring my template thank you
I know thank you okay guys
big shout out can you let me know
whether the volume is okay the volume is
okay we're happy with the volume because
I'm gonna I'm gonna play it if
everyone's happy with the volume is
everyone happy with the volume let me
know now and then I'm gonna play it we
can hear but it could be better yeah
should I try with my airpods okay could
be better with the airpods we're trying
to do this for you we're trying to make
this perfect for you guys all right
let's see
airports in
the concerns about the things I say I
think the concern is for the level of
influence I had and the reach I have
I would argue maybe tell yourself
the fact that I have a massively
influential over the
[Music]
absolutely not
emotional discouraging yeah
firstly let's begin
okay
so
straight away this woman is on the
offense
straight away she's like have you oh
anybody have you trafficked anybody so
we know straight away that this woman
is not happy with him I actually still
think my brother's in the other room so
get if you can hear this I think people
in the chat can hear you you need to you
need to you need to tie me down
yeah see I get I can still hear you you
need to you need to get you need to put
your earphones in
okay
let's start at the beginning
I'm facing charges the one the first
ones you mentioned the rape ones already
start out by a judge
secondly it's very difficult for me to
sit here in a very Frank and honest
conversation with you while we're in the
territory of Romania about illegal cases
going on with the remaining I have to
protect myself I've agreed to do an
interview with you and I want to be as
honest with you as possible but I can't
incriminate myself in any way I have to
be very careful with what I talk about
are no charges yet correct there are no
charges said that there are no charges
and I would and I've agreed to speak to
you but I have to be as honest and Frank
as I can while also protecting myself
and following my legal counsel so let's
talk about what you've said yourself
then you have said on the website for
your original website for the Hoskins
University that you emotionally
manipulated women to fall in love with
you so that you could get them working
in the sex industry for your financial
gain as I said I have to be very careful
with what I say but let's put it this
way no women are coming out against me
and accusing me of doing it yes they are
no they're not yes they are well they're
not who there's testimony from the
current investigation the current
investigation which I cannot discuss
which I know intimately and you don't I
can tell you right now that the the
women who are in this case File there
are two American women who have been
caught already admitting their lying and
then nobody else is accusing me of
anything to begin with it's very common
in cases like this that the alleged
victims do not always see themselves as
victims well that's very interesting
it's actually extremely interesting
because if I was
a matrix controlled
organization my goal was to slander
somebody and try and destroy their name
you're telling me that they've chosen a
crime which one is heinous of course
because it damages the person's
credibility in two you're saying that
even if everyone else involved if you
have five people everyone's sitting
there saying no nobody's hurt anybody we
like Andrew we've all work together
we're friends Etc not what anybody says
let me read you some of the testimony
from the current investigation
one of the witnesses guys this is giving
me Piers Morgan Vibes she's doing the
typical thing where
the person is just not allowed to finish
their sentence Andrew's not allowed to
finish his sentence and actually if you
heard what he said he said rape is one
of the most I should say a lot on
YouTube R is one of the most heinous
crimes but also it's one of the worst
crimes you can um be accused of because
there's no evidence so it becomes so
difficult it becomes so he says she says
um all right let's keep going
you're not answering the question I am
asking questions
you're saying the people who are
involved in this even if they say
they're not victims that they're still
going to try and attack names treated as
victims by the case that's ongoing and
not all of them are saying that one of
the witnesses says
we can't just we can't go into the case
the case is open and active
well let's just be clear that not all of
the Witnesses in the case are behaving
in the way you describe this is so crazy
so this is a BBC journalist who is
having to be told that there are things
legally that they're not allowed to talk
about you would think that the BBC would
know
what you are what you aren't allowed to
talk about especially in the UK you have
an ethical code of conduct you have laws
you have media law you have
um I think it's called contempt of court
when you talk about certain things which
you're not allowed to talk about because
obviously there's an ongoing case how
does a BBC journalist not know this this
is already she's already losing her
credibility here
and even those that are it doesn't
bother them from being treated as
victims by the prosecution by the case
we have an open criminal investigation I
am absolutely not really sure how we
found innocent I know the case better
than you I know intimately and you don't
I have seen all the criminal files and
the evidence against me and you haven't
I know the truth of what happened and
you don't and I'm telling you absolutely
not really I've never hurt anybody that
the case that's been put against me is
completely not be fabricated and I've
never really found guilty of anything
and it's very difficult for me to answer
your in-depth questions because we're
sitting here inside of the territory of
Romania I'm holding to the Romanian
legal system and I'm not going to
incriminate myself because you're trying
to Prague me you are wrong and we're
gonna have to accept that for now and
ask and talk about something else let me
read you then what you have said about
what you have done sure you have said my
job was to meet a girl go on a few dates
sleep with her get her to fall in love
with me to the point where she'd do
anything I say and then get her on
webcam so we could become rich together
I don't think that's what I personally
said I think that's exactly that's no
I've never said that that's something
that you found I'm not using that
doesn't mean I've said it and and again
once again if any female on the planet
has a problem with me I strongly
recommend her to go to the police and
try and pursue me for criminal charges
it's actually very interesting that me
one of the most famous people in the
world who's been vilified by the Legacy
Media and places all over the Internet
while everyone has attacked me from
every single angle while federal
agencies from multiple countries have
called over 2 000 women who know you we
stand here with zero new accusations
since my arrest zero if you took any
famous person any man of substantial
wealth and you called 2 000 women who
knew him and find an ex-girlfriend is
upset somebody who wants money who's
upset they call 2 000 people who knew me
and could not find a single woman to
make a new complaint the only the only
complaints they have against me are the
initial complaints which we can prove
Our Lives and that's where it stands so
I I'm not going to sit here and allow
you to pretend that I'm some kind of
evil Predator when actually I'd argue
the fact I'd argue the fact that people
have been investigated to the level I've
been investigated to if you're the
average man on the street and
investigate his entire life for 14
months ago everyone who's ever known you
and vilify him in the media and
encourage people to come forward for
money and you try to contact every ex
girlfriend I'm accused those people of
rape and accusation I think that you
would have a lot more I think you would
have a lot more Flack than I've got I'm
actually such a nice person
to somebody so just on that I want to go
back a sec Andrew made a really
interesting point and I do um take this
as fact I do believe this to be
completely true when you're a man and
you have and you have a certain level of
status fame money you will always have
accusations against you you can be the
nicest person in the world but people
won't like you and so naturally there
will be accusations against you it's
just the most obvious thing to happen
and I also agree I think that those
people who have investigated him to this
extent are the evil people this guy's
been banned from like every single
platform I think he's even banned from
Uber
um and and there's been and and there's
been no um there's been no guilty charge
and he's banned from absolutely
everything you think Google as well
banned him it's crazy
it's your arrest who says exactly those
things that with you it's all
manipulation there's an ulterior is this
something everything is this Sophie
the fake name no face let me take it
back up in the media and encourage
people to come forward for money and you
try to contact everybody would come
forward and accuse those people of rape
and accusations I think that you would
have a lot more I think you would have a
lot more flat than I've got I'm actually
such a nice person that I've never had
anything spoken to somebody sits your
arrest who says exactly those things
that with you it's all manipulation
there's an ulterior is this Sophie who
is Sophie oh it's Sophie the fake name
no face
to please him and wanting him to be
happy
that I was just kind of yeah okay do
whatever you want and what if she had
used the other Prime this imaginary
Sophie she's making the point that there
is actually accused me of a crime
I'm asking you a question correct but
you're not the boss here because I've
allowed you into my house I'm asking you
the question correctly and I'm telling
you you get to decide no we are equal
here I've allowed you into my house you
don't come here with a position of
authority I'm doing you the favor of
Legacy Media giving you relevance I'm
speaking to you and I'm telling you now
this Sophie Richard BBC is invented
which is no face of nobody knows who she
is
you remember and she's not she's
not she's the world Sophie was the
person she did the interview with the
BBC and she had like a voice changer
imaginary that's why he keeps saying
imaginary remember yeah yeah yeah but
that's what I mean like who is Sophie
and I love how Andrew's like you don't
have any Authority here like everyone
hates Legacy Media over the last three
years we've just seen how all the Legacy
Media doers lie and now suddenly and so
Andrew is nice enough to let them in his
home he like this this Lucy got the
first interview I haven't even had a my
interview with and my second interview
with Andrew yeah he gave it to Lucy and
Lucy's there calling the shots
you should have had me first yeah I know
yeah but we're gonna do it I should have
gone to Romania I should have done that
we're gonna do with the our second
interview will be the greatest interview
ever yeah I should have done this
yes this is my brother by the way people
are asking in the comments Lucy is a bot
for sure he's an NPC bot she's so she's
so yeah she looks horrible as well she
looks so gone and so malnourished it's
like that's what wokeness does to you
yeah that's what I mean it's like she
looks like the liberal Lefty kind of
woman
she looks horrible like she's just out
there to attack him they buy love how
he's like this is my house this is so
like when you're in my house these are
my rules
and you follow my rule anyway
s all right let's keep let's keep going
wait I want to go back a bit oh no I'll
just play it
what are we talking about what is she
say anything about emotional
manipulation how she's the sex industry
for your
charges against me I welcome anybody who
believes I've harmed a male or female
any point in the past all criminal
charges against me I'll fight them I
know who I am and I know what I've done
and I know the truth and I know that
I'll be found innocent of this attack
the reason I'm being attacked is because
of my massive influence not because I've
ever hurt anybody and for you to sit
here and say that everybody around you
is saying you're Innocent but that
doesn't matter because the state will
say they're victims and they're just
gonna
grab everybody you know and call
everybody victims even if they say
they're not and try and put you in jail
you are describing a matrix attack
you're not describing human trafficking
I'm describing women who are going to
court to accuse you of rape in human
trafficking we will see what women do we
will see what women go to court and then
finish trials we'll see which women go
we'll see which one we live for I'm
describing women who are going to court
to accuse you of raping himself
I'm describing women who have spoken to
the BBC at least and other media
organizations about what they say is
emotional manipulation and coercion and
I'm quoting back to you your own words
where you describe
the words you found on the internet and
Sophie doesn't exist so let's move on to
the next subject move on to the next
subject no I think I'll stick on this
one for a minute so there's other places
in that same website where you say you
get girls to fall in love with you and
they do it because they love you because
they want to do what you say
convincing women to take part in some
kind of business Arrangement doesn't
work long term because they're emotional
you've got to get people in love with
you
once again that's emotional manipulation
that's abuse what you've found are clips
from the internet some text from the
internet and you're going to sit here
and tell me that that's the reason
actually your website your words
yes it is no saw
check my website next
the website you've taken down and I
wonder why those comments have been
taken no websites no websites been
thinking now my website is the same it's
been the same for a very long time the
comments on
you are accusing me I'm guessing what
you're trying to say is you're accusing
me you're trying to say that I'm guilty
of the things I'm accused of and I'm
emotionally manipulating people I'm
saying that you have said you
emotionally manipulated people here for
your own Financial getting no absolutely
not and I'm asking you about that
absolutely not is the answer I look
forward to the end of this try I look
forward to clearing my name I look
forward to the BBC and the Legacy Media
having to say not guilty and having to
tell the truth as I've said before the
only other person who's been found
despite absolute rigorous destructive
levels of investigation and prodding
into my life it's just imaginary Sophie
by the BBC who doesn't exist and if you
were to find any single other man on
Earth and try and analyze his life
forensically to the level they've done
mine you would find genuine damaged
people I don't hurt people
it's not just thousands of women have
come out in my defense thousands of
women have come out my defense and
you've not mentioned that thousands of
women
let's agree that
let's agree that sounds problem that
some people say you haven't done it it's
a problem that some people say you have
thousands of women come out my defense
and as we stand right now we have open
criminal investigation people who are
involved in the criminal investigation
are saying that we're not victims of
anything Andrew's fine he's never heard
of us you're saying no I have the
opposite to that I have to counter that
I have someone called Sophie with no
face a fake name who we've invented and
she's not accusing you of anything
criminal so I don't see the whole point
manipulate women they say women why
women people think you do I'm not here
do you think I'm manipulating you I'm
asking you about it
given on your website and the testimony
you've printed something off that you
found on Reddit
that makes me a bad person if I'm saying
that you should know better as a
journalist and do some proper journalism
let's investigate the fact that you
should answer my questions
I already have and we should move on
she's just trying to start hard it's not
only about the criminal
like a much bigger issue
children's organized organized in the UK
you've got rape organizations in the UK
you've got the police naming You by name
as someone who has a harmful influence
on children and on women in the UK and
elsewhere because of the things you say
because of the way you present
gender relations the way you say men
should treat women that's very upsetting
this is going to get interesting because
I know that's not true I'm genuinely a
good person I believe my impact on the
world is positive in fact if you were to
read the comments section of nearly any
video I post especially by the Legacy
Media 95 of the population agree with me
most people know the things I say are
positive Legacy Media as a whole has
lost all its credibility in the last
three to four years yeah and it's a
shame it's a massive shame the BBC come
here and try and push and purport this
idea that I'm a dangerous person
I'm anti-drug so I've never pushed drugs
or any uh I'm anti drugs or
anti-violence we're the UK is facing a
nice crime epidemic they're going to sit
here and say that I'm the most dangerous
man in the UK yeah
in the world I've said I'm the most
dangerous man in the world
you've also said that a woman's intimate
Parts belong to her male part
I find it funny that you're sitting here
saying that I said I'm the most
dangerous man in the world and you
believe that's when did I say that I'm
asking if you believe it no you said you
said you said you're the most dangerous
man in the world is that some kind of
proof that I'm dangerous am I Dr Evil
now I'm telling you that it's very upset
that you're gonna sit here and that
certain organizations in the world are
going to try and pretend that I'm the
biggest force of evil on earth when I'm
genuinely a Force for good I'm genuinely
and the reason they're doing this is
because of the massive influence I have
over the youth and they don't like that
I'm telling the youth to think outside
the Matrix and ignore things like the
BBC which come here with loaded
questions and false narratives and try
and paint innocent people as as guilty
you said women's intimate Parts belong
to their male part I said that if a
woman marries a man she takes his last
name and traditionally the man gives her
away I've been pushing traditional
religious beliefs because I'm a
religious man and traditional beliefs in
regards to marriage which everybody
accepted 10 to 15 years ago so that's
not that's not that's not a crazy
conspiracy theory if you're going to sit
here and say that me believing a woman
should take a Man's last name in
marriage makes me the most dangerous man
in the world then you're just going to
lose you in more credibility that the
BBC's already lost in the last four to
five years yeah that's your point if
that's your narrative
uh okay this is getting crazy I just
want to say in times of the most
dangerous amount of the world um Andrew
has a point the UK is literally facing a
knife crime issue like I don't live in
London anymore because it's one of the
most dangerous places what about
terrorist organizations what about
governments that start wars what about
central banks that print money and
people which causes crazy amounts of
inflation pushing people deeper into
poverty this is far more dangerous than
a man on the internet preaching
traditional gender roles these people
are insane all right I think it's going
to get juicy let's keep going able to
sleep with a lot of women outside
marriage that doesn't sound very
religious that's not what I said they
should be able to I said a lot of high
value men a lot of rich men do it and
then we discussed at length on podcasts
why Richmond do it and we also discussed
why women decide to be unfaithful it's
not a gendered argument we discuss
unfaithfulness as a whole what are the
reasons and motivations for men and what
are the reason motivations for women
because you have no time to actually say
it because you have no time to actually
watch my content because you have no
time to actually watch my content like
and understand what I'm saying you just
come here with a small snippet which can
be provided doesn't make it true no
that's the point isn't it these
journalists that come to interview him
like they haven't watched the content I
feel like if they actually sat down and
watched the content for like a good you
know just even half a day I feel like
they'd have a completely different
perspective really you don't have a clue
what I say or what I talk about you
never watch my content you have small
pieces of paper small Clips are on a
piece of paper and you're trying to
pretend I've said evil things and then
you're going to send the most dangerous
man in the world which is truly love you
said that
do you believe I'm the most dangerous
man in the world
question well then we well then we need
to change the dynamic of this interview
because I'll make this clear I allowed
you into my home I'm doing you a favor
give me diversity you don't come here
with a position of authority you're not
the police I don't respect I don't know
you you do not come here with a pursuit
of authority over me we are equals we
are people we're citizens and we sit
here as equals and I see you as my equal
and if you have some questions I can ask
your questions back for you to come here
and sit down and pretend you're the
Christopher that's my question it's
disingenuous because
this is a conversation and I don't owe
you any degree of authority that's
correct so let's make that clear and
that doesn't matter to a man or a woman
or from the BBC or the CNN I'm here to
answer your questions and be honest with
you and do you a favor you think she'd
know this is Andrew Tate this isn't just
like some random person that she's
interviewing and it's just gonna bow
down because oh my God the BBC came to
my house like Andrew doesn't need her
and to be honest like
he knew what he was doing having his
first interview with the BBC and also
before I continue this I just want to
make the point it's hilarious that they
sent a woman of course they sent a woman
of course they sent a woman I mean just
as a side point I don't know if you guys
saw the interview with them think with
the BBC and Elon Musk they sent the most
feminine man they they're just as Donald
Trump once said they're just not sending
their best right let's keep going
but and I'm doing you a favor when you
come here with load of questions you're
trying to paint an error for me which is
negative I'm asking you and that's fine
I've said that people are concerned
about it and that's fine but you're not
going to sit here and say you don't
answer my questions because you're not
above me
absolutely it would help if you answered
the question I've answered every
question so far let me ask you another
question sure you have said a woman's
intimate Parts belong to her male
partner and if she goes on only fans he
is entitled to a cut of her income you
are extremely it's actually very it's
very confusing to me why you're gonna
sit here take long format podcasts I've
done which are three or four hours long
in context where I sat with only fans
girls 10 or 15 only fans girls where
we've been joking back and forth ignore
every comment and satirical comment and
sarcastic comment that the females have
made and then come along and say you
said this and that you're the most evil
man in the world I don't know if you
understand sarcasm I don't know if you
understand it requires context that's
the point
so you're saying you're sarcastic I'm
saying it was a very interesting talk
show and for you to sit here and say
that that is my true core beliefs and
that let's give that person is
disingenuous of course not was it
sarcasm absolutely you should watch the
show these people don't have a sense of
humor
you should watch the show let me clarify
for the audience you were being
sarcastic when you said a woman's
intimate Parts belong to her male
partner no I didn't believe that no it's
not that it's that you haven't watched
the show and you should have because the
woman was saying my man's car belongs to
me because he's my man and she was on
only things and then 20 minutes later
when she said she was one only fans and
said ah well you're selling your body
that belongs him because he's your man
and she laughed she laughed she laughed
and she said haha yeah that's probably
true if you watch this you see she oh my
God this is why I get so frustrated
because everything requires Nuance
everything requires context and I
actually haven't seen this clip but
Andrew's saying the girl laughed the
girl laughed it's just a bit of like fun
uncensored chit chat on a podcast and
this woman as Andrew says is like the
Gestapo but do you believe it like who
cares it's just so ridiculous is this
like what um the world has come down to
our biggest issues in society is whether
Andrew was telling a joke or not it's
just so weird I I don't know I must be
the only one who finds this really
bizarre
for the show if you watch the show it
will make sense for you to come here
with doing no research at all and then
say I don't understand what I'm talking
about but I've got this piece of paper
with a few things printed off that's why
you're saying the silly things you're
saying did you watch the show do some
research do you believe it it's
irrelevant I've already answered the
question
a woman's intimate Parts belong to her
male of course not I've just answered
the question
and does this woman believe that her
man's car belongs to her
we it's not a gendered argument I really
yeah that's the point like why don't
they go Grill the only fans girl and ask
them do you really believe that that
your man's car is yours because because
you're married to him I mean like it's
ridiculous it's they're trying they're
reaching too much I think that that it's
genuinely sad
that when the BBC has a chance to
finally interview me at the end of all
this week yeah exactly but they don't
come here with any kind of genuine
openness to try and understand my
influence of the world or the things I
push or what I'm trying to teach the
world or why I'm a good influence on the
world because
they said they come here with pieces of
paper printed out excerpts from
five-year-old podcasts taken out of
context to attend the same to attempt
the same Matrix attack on me which has
been attempted endlessly to every single
person Legacy Media has already you
tried this and it doesn't work do I
really encourage you I encourage you to
read the comment section on the on
YouTube when this goes on YouTube and
you will see that nobody believes a word
you're saying yeah
is because we've got the chief executive
of great price it's naming you
individually as spreading a dangerous
ideology of misogynistic rape culture
absolutely who is that guy comments you
make that are leading people to say
things like absolute National
organizations who are saying that
blaming you for increasing levels of
misogyny schools that are saying they
are schools are stupid increased
incidents of girls being attacked
female teachers being harrised if that
was if that wasn't you and your teacher
that's absolutely that's absolute
garbage I have never
okay I just want to make this really
clear
how people choose to interpret Andrew's
message
is how the kids choose to interpret it
it's down to the parents and the
parenting
because you have people like
lizzo and cardi B and Nicki Minaj who
were like shaking their naked bodies and
glorifying prostitution and all this
stuff and nobody suddenly worried about
the effects that that's gonna have on
young girls no we leave it to the
parents to to
um to help the young girls and teach
them right from wrong but suddenly when
a man is being loud and having an
influencer it's not okay it's literally
down to the parents what about how
disgusting and sorry this might offend
people but like how disgusting the words
are in rap music
is does that not have an effect on
violence and young boys and how they are
in school no nobody cares nobody does
anything
so this double standard here
you see what I mean
I might take them seriously if they
start Banning cardi B who you literally
used to like drug men
um what about even Cosmo magazine
promoting uh promoting obesity like are
we gonna ban these things because
they're bad no just Andrew so I don't
take that what I'm saying is I don't
take their um I don't take them very
seriously because they don't follow
through with that logic
ever encourage a student to attack a
teacher male or female ever
discipline I'm an athlete I preach
anti-drug I preach religion I preach no
alcohol I preach uh no knife crime every
single problem with modern society I'm
against I'm teaching young men I'm
teaching young men to be disciplined to
be diligent to listen to train to work
hard to be exactly like me with no
criminal record never even yet charged
in this 14-month Matrix investigation
and I'm saying that men grow up like me
which are hard-working and diligent and
it's emotional control and stoic we're
gonna have a better Society not a worse
Society to sit here and say that schools
in England England which is a failing
nation which has a nice crime going
through the roof violence going through
the roof men's mental health going
through the roof and they're gonna all
blame me because I appeared on the
internet one year ago it's disingenuous
it's disingenuous and also also
financial success
but it comes with side order of misogyny
how does having a Bugatti and a cigar
come with a massage
[Applause]
when a woman comes home and accuses you
of cheating you should hit her with a
machete shovel is that what I is that
what I teach
you say no if you actually watch the
game it will be about the woman
attacking me with a machete as usual
you've not watched the video taken out
of context flipped it and attempted it
to attack me with a small excerpt let me
tell you something Lucy I'm sure you're
a very nice person I'm sure you're a
fantastic person but if I were to take
everything you've ever said online and
just take small excerpts out of context
I could make you look like a misogynist
I guarantee it in fact I might actually
do that and then you're gonna sit here
and say oh I'm a misogynist because
my Clips have been taken out of context
if you refuse to wash anything at length
and understand it
the National Police Chiefs leave for
violence against women the nspcc Rape
Crisis safer schools they are all naming
you so as being behind are these
authorities misogyny even an epidemic of
misogyny the what an act sorry an
epidemic of misogyny these words that
they an academic misogyny I'm sorry it's
a bit ridiculous you know what I mean
like like it reminds me of like the
pandemic the epidemic what about the
knife crime you know what about an
epidemic of obesity which lizzo is
spreading you know what about an
epidemic of a young girl sleeping around
and getting pregnant which cardi B is
talking about an epidemic of misogyny I
mean it's like it's oh my God
like it's crazy even amongst primary
school children the idea that I've made
primary school children misogynistic
because I own a nice car
is that you're wrong is that your
argument that comes along with it oh
holding a nice park
guys so if if my man buys me a nice car
and I drive it that means I'm a
misogynist according to Lucy and Legacy
Media
got it
along with it how does misogyny come on
with only a nice car
you have you have an image of financial
I'm glad you're answering my questions
now we finally got the name
image financial success you have an
image of final Financial Journey comes
along with attitudes towards women that
are really problematic my attitudes
towards women is that when she was
protected and provided for and I've said
that at night in fact I've said that
over 50 times online you never mention
it I say that my girlfriend doesn't have
to work unless she wants to I take care
of her I die to protect the woman I've
talked about how I've stood up and faced
a knife to protect a woman
a child or a dog absolutely well see
Andrea's going to say no but I would
argue like that's a fair that's a fair
trade-off
you know like it depends it depends like
what kind of man a woman picks but if
you pick a strong if you pick a strong
man that's more intelligent than you and
most women do then it will sort of make
sense to follow his lead and his
authority you know like that just
naturally makes sense women are
hypergamous we date upwards so yeah you
probably should follow his lead and his
authority
but you have responsibility for someone
like a child or a dog you say you have
authority over them if you want to go
down this argument we'll go down this
nuanced argument I said that if I have
responsibility for her safety I should
have a degree of authority over her
safety meaning meaning and let me
explain my point if I'm the one who has
to fight and die to protect her I'm the
one who decides how we walk home I'm the
one who decides to group retake because
it's unfair of her to say I want to walk
through the most dangerous neighborhood
in the world but you have to fix the
knives yeah that's what I've said I know
you're going to sit here and pretend I'm
trying to treat women like dogs this is
such a good point and actually it's a
point which my brother actually
explained to me because I think on face
value you're not going to fully
understand it but like as a woman if you
expect your man to protect you
um if a man comes up to you on the
street or somebody comes to stabs you or
whatever it is and you expect your man
to protect you then you shouldn't as a
woman you should make sure to not put
him in a position where he has to risk
his life to protect you this kind of
comes back to the whole man deciding
what a woman should wear
so like like my brother pointed this out
to me so if you're if a woman is out
with a man and whatever their husband
wife girlfriend boyfriend whatever they
are and she's wearing something
extremely revealing
he may say go change your clothes she
may not like that the reason he says
change your clothes is because they're
going to go out together and other men
are gonna hit on her in front of him
he's then gonna have to go to battle and
start fighting and then it's the whole
thing so what she could do is you know
wear something a little bit less
provocative so it doesn't cause all this
drama and everybody sees her and then he
doesn't have to start a fight with
someone and then nobody gets hurt you
know if the man is going to defend This
Woman's honor then like let's not put
him in a position where he has to be at
risk that's
I don't think it's that bad I think it's
pretty normal
which is garbage every single man every
single man in the world who loves this
woman understands that he has to protect
her and every single woman in the world
likes the idea of a woman of a man who
would protect her if you were to say to
most women home right now do you want
your husband to protect you in a violent
attack they'd say yeah of course nothing
I've said is most women would you want
to lose Authority in the relationship
yes
I didn't say that I said I need to have
authority over the route we walk home
when you compare women and the authority
over women that you believe you should
have to having authority over a child or
a dog it's not the same because a woman
is a free legal adult correct you're
equal free legal adult my equal but if I
had a girlfriend we were walking home
late at night and I said let's not walk
down the area it's a bad area I protect
everything happens I want to take the
long way and she said no I will I have
to walk this way even though it's the
most dangerous room I must then what
then I would say you're welcome to you
could do it you're a free legal equal
but I'm not going to walk with you and
protect you I think that I should be
able to decide to work because I have an
obligation and my obligation as a man is
to protect and provide for females
everything I'm talking about is Gen is
traditional gender roles which 10 years
ago less than 10 years ago would not be
considered outlandish would not be
considered crazy would not be considered
dangerous or misogynistic the world has
changed and a lot of people haven't
changed with the world please understand
there's a lot of women at home watching
this right now who like the idea of a
man sticking up for them and protecting
them and providing for them and just
because the world has gone crazy and the
Legacy Media has gone crazy most people
at home are still relatively sane and
these are the people who are going to
write on the comments that Andrew was
saying anything
other people
what's happening
this isn't like the whole world believes
these things it's true there's so many
normal people still out there
I'm reading all your comments by the way
I can see everything
it's fine
her husband is probably a daily consumer
of McDonald's and KFC yeah I'm enjoying
she's not look at that
look how angry she is he's happy she's
so angry all right I might move this on
I don't know what's going on
talking about
the time I'm saying if someone broke at
your house would you want your husband
it's not about conservative values or
protection it's what you're demanding in
return for that well I'll give you this
I don't know if your husband is I don't
know if you would say enough to protect
you and die for you but I'll give you
this if someone broke into this house
right now it was a homicidal maniac I
would expect me and the other men in
this room to stand up and face them
while you and when you and the other
women in this room could protect
yourselves I would actually believe the
men should go and engage with you I
believe that and even though I don't
know you and you've come into my house
with a hostile agenda and you've come
here to try and make me look bad
I would still stand up I would you stand
up to protect you I would still stand up
productive because I believe that's my
role as a man that's very honorable I am
asking you about things that you have
said and have caused major national
organizations including the police oh
the police
I don't know if you guys know but um
there was um a policeman in the UK who
recently raped someone I should say that
word who recently raped someone so like
I don't really take the police with much
uh Authority or credibility they're also
like holding hands with um LGBT people
during like pride month like singing
Rainbow things so like I don't really
take peace with so much Authority
that's what I'm asking you it's not what
I say it's not about whether you protect
your partner or not it's about what you
have said that has caused such concern
in the UK and I want to put it to you
that you don't really care about the
harm it cause that's not true it is
because that's not true making
controversial statements like this
online has made you a lot of money okay
so first thing I genuinely am a Force
for good in the world you may not
understand that yet but you will
eventually and I genuinely believe I'm
acting under the instruction of God to
do good things and I want to make the
world a better place I believe my legacy
is a good Legacy and I believe that
eventually when the Legacy Media catches
up they're going to understand I'm a
good positive influence I'm not
interested in damaging the world for
money because if I was interested in
damaging the world for money I could
have sold drugs or I could make rap
music and encourage everyone to stab
each other like all the drill artists do
well you can make controversial
statements online that attract a lot of
followers who you then direct to your
website this is the point this is what I
wear this is the exact point that I
raised earlier why don't they go speak
to the UK artists that do rap and drill
music and encourage people to stop
people like there's such an issue with
stabbings in the UK like it has its own
slogan knife crime UK like it's it's a
slogan you know why don't they go and
investigate all of these rappers and
maybe that could help with knife crime
instead of worrying about Andrew's
traditional gender roles and God complex
was what I was the word that I was going
for
I could wait I could make jokes I mean I
could make I could make jokes online who
does
no I'm saying that these organizations
and the BBC are going to sit here and
pretend that I am the face damaging the
youth is absolutely garbage it's
completely disingenuous and the reason
and the reason
s to ask questions
and this is not a conversation that we
were very good at the questions
has been provided so if we could please
move on from this side of the interview
I would appreciate it I would like to
hear what yeah that's a good point
that when you make controversial
statements it attracts people to follow
you
and then you direct them to your website
where they pay you a monthly fee to
learn how to be like you and so the more
controversial statements when she says
it is kind of funny more money you get
the fact that that's the path you've
outlined to one like online university
and to my presence on the internet the
fact that you believe that's the path
just shows you've done absolute
resilience
genuinely zero research okay so how many
of the people
who's genuinely serious how many of the
people they're relevant because the
social media world through your social
media where you direct them to the
website and Lucy I encourage you to go
out there do some genuine research watch
my videos watch my videos at night and
truly understand what I'm doing how many
of the people who sign up for Hustlers
University of 49.99 a month come to you
why does it matter that it's financing
on your social media she's trying to
make it it's an online school
University which I don't own I influence
more along with many other influencers
and they sign up for your website which
I don't own and once again that's once
again once once once again that's
nothing to do with me and you're gonna
sit here and say that I made a joke I
made a joke online four years ago
because a woman said that she owned her
man's car and you made a joke and that
means that you because you forget it was
misogynistic dangerous man in the world
this is going down a path of absolute
Insanity it's not true none of this is
true I don't hurt people I don't harm
people I'm genuinely a positive person
I'm I'm renowned
I'm actually renowned for helping young
men because we talk about those immense
Mental Health crisis we talk about we
pretend to care that men are upset as
soon as I discuss men's issues it's
misogynistic it doesn't have to be
gender just because I believe men have a
point of view and men have rights and
men are allowed to think and believe and
act a certain way that helps them
internally that doesn't mean it's
anti-female in fact I believe it's
actually Pro female I think what a man
is true to his influence and true to his
s's and he's good within himself he's a
positive influence in the world he's
positive for the women around it just
because I discuss men's issues people
say oh you're anti-woman I'm not
anti-woman I love women why are so many
women saying that when their boyfriends
start following you they're not they
experience more control so many to be
fair I've actually heard so many people
say I've had a lot of women say as soon
as their husbands started following tape
their marriage got better so two slides
to every coin isn't there Lucy
experience
enough
name names loose so in fact one is too
many oh of course yeah so of in fact
I've seen thousands and thousands of
comments of common endless email
crazy the fact praising the fact that
their sons are listening to me it's
crazy the fact that the things I'm
saying does not worry it would worry it
would work
it would worry me if I was genuinely
damaging the world but for you to sit
here and say Andrew you become the most
Googled man in the world you have
billions of views and one woman one is
now saying that her husband is not the
same man she wants him to be when
thousands and thousands of people are
saying the opposite well then I would
say that
you are genuinely concerned about the
impact you're having and you brush it
off as if it's nothing no what you have
done is come here with an agenda you
come here with loaded questions you've
come here with things like map of
context you come here with things that
you don't understand it's satirical and
then you're gonna also say that one
woman said that her boyfriend changed
when he watched one of your videos and
and then I don't know what you expect me
to say to that that's fantastic and
jokes no that's how you explain it but
it's enough for you to sit down you'd
like to apologize for any of that for
you to sit down no don't apologize
it's fine no it's fine it's easy for you
to sit down and say that one woman said
that her boyfriend watched an Andrew
take video and now he won't do the
dishes or whatever your argument is and
that I'm somehow the worst most
dangerous yeah but like schools are also
promoting that like there are 100
genders and that kids should change them
without their parents permission so like
you know I won't really call school's
the best uh
we'll give schools all the credibility
or the best source of morality or right
from wrong
it's just disingenuous and I'm enjoying
this interview very much because this
shows this shows the world it's great it
shows the world the truth about the
Legacy Media because they beg me for
interviews they they beg me you have
been begging me for months please we
need to need to be relevant and then you
come here with loaded questions trying
to paint a picture of me which is
completely and utterly false I am a good
positive influence for the world the
things I teach men are stoicism
discipline self-respect hard work
obeying Authority listening to your
fight coach working hard in school
making as much money as possible in your
job if you actually watch the things I
say if you actually watch my comments
about women I've done a long podcasts
for hours long about females talking
about protecting to them provided for
them how I believe women should be
treated in a relationship I've done all
of this but you don't watch any of it
and then you come here and ask me that
answer questions I've answered at length
thousands of times since you came out of
custody
there seems to have been a lot about
your charity work correct on your social
there's all I've always done the charity
work but now I'm promoting it there
seems to be a real shift yeah
yeah well I've always won the charity
work I've been doing the charity work
for years I believe that it's my if I
can see the positive influence on the
world and I've been doing charity work
for over five years post
my incarceration my unfair unjust
incarceration mad
post that I've made it more clear to the
charity work I'm doing but this is again
once again very interesting I spend 25
million dollars a year feeding children
men male children and female children in
in turkey and Syria and Iran and Iraq I
actually spend 25 million dollars a year
yeah what's Lucy doing like what's Lucy
doing other than coming over to this
man's house like did she ever bring
chocolates you know what I mean like
what's Lucy doing other than coming in
with a plate of disrespect she filled it
is she feeding the homeless probably
children and I'm still the worst man in
the world four years ago I made a
sarcastic comment because some people
you got money from attracting people to
your website by making controversial
comments but that might have got you
into trouble and so now you're looking
for a new market you're looking for a
new market of followers who are
attracted by a different sort of persona
I've always done the charity work so
that is obviously correct and I have
proof that I've always on the charity
work so you're wrong first I believe
that if you have a lot of wealth you
should help people and I'm helping
people I honestly think it's very very
interesting that you cannot find another
celebrity in the UK or anywhere else
who's spending 25 million pounds a year
feeding children in war-torn countries
I'm doing that and I've been doing that
for a long time without even mentioning
I never even said it and now that I've
said it people are going to attack me
for it and say that it's disingenuous
that's the craziest thing about charity
so like you can do charity and nobody
knows about it and they'll call you a
bad person
and then you can do charity and you then
you promote it online and then everybody
calls you a bad person you literally
can't win my thing is like to do what
you want to do
don't live for other people and you
should just keep going the person in
Sudan who's eating a meal do you think
they believe it's disingenuous no I
think I think they feel pretty good that
Andrew take this fed then and to sit
here and say that I'm a bad person now
because I'm manipulating charity because
I'm using cherry I'm just trying to do
good in the world that's all I've ever
been trying to do
when women speak out against you online
disagree with what you say they describe
being bombarded with rape threats with
death threats okay let's talk about this
all right guys we need to talk about
this ASAP okay we need to talk about
this ASAP I have been speaking out
against cardi B lizzo more recently I
think like some news Publications picked
me up yesterday uh Nicki Minaj the
stallion uh like all of those women I've
been speaking out about how they're such
bad role models for women you should see
the state of my DMs I've had death
threats grape threats uh people have
said people have wished death to put my
family members these are young girls
and they are all part of this cult
they're all part of the lizzo Nicki
Minaj cult and yeah the stallion I don't
know her name I don't listen to that
music I listen to country music all
these people have been sending me death
threats just because I said that lizzo
is a bad role model for women cardi B is
a bad role model for women do we blame
lizzo for her followers and how
emotional they behave know so we can't
really do the same thing with Tate or
perhaps we should but if we do if we do
that with Andrew then again by that
logic we should treat everyone the same
otherwise that's just sexist right the
women are just getting better treatment
would you like to say anything to your
followers about how to behave and that's
absolutely correct I would love to do
that first things first I've yet to see
a female stand up and
I don't ever see hardly any well only
women who message the agree with
secondly I don't think that anybody who
disagrees with me male or female should
be trolled I don't think they should be
assaulted or attacked I think the idea
should be discussed openly and fairly
immature it doesn't matter what man
agrees with me or disagrees with me or a
female I don't think my followers should
come along and attack her and if my
followers are doing that I'm upset by
that but
let's make a very important
clarification that's not my followers
that's the internet if you were to log
into any video game Lobby I don't think
and some were to sit there and say
something stupid they would be trolled
with similar comments that's the
unfortunate reality of the internet as a
whole that's nothing to do with me but I
encourage all of my followers to open to
engage in open discourse and be fair and
honest and talk in a way which is mature
something you control anybody male or
female
okay
he would like to apologize what
give
you know an indication of how he feels
about the allegations that he has
negatively influenced young people who
secondly I think we should be on records
but this interview is taking place in
your house because you're under house
arrest if it were not for that then you
wouldn't choosing another location like
sharing for me to negotiated that
between us
so I think that's just
okay
um
then you said that you've invited us
into your house we're here because
you're under house arrest correct if you
were free to leave we would have
negotiated a morning
don't you think as the BBC it would be
very interesting to come here and
discuss the fact that I was put in a
dungeon for 92 days yeah and then walked
in hamster rest without charge don't you
think that's a far more interesting
conversation than old YouTube
because there's a going investigation
into rape and human trafficking
allegations again correct I've been
incarcerated without charge don't you
think
it's been dropped
correct so I am I'm I'm incarcerated
without charge and I think that'd be a
far more incarcerated yes Julian Assange
is incarcerated without charge yeah
exactly if you actually wanted to do
some genuine journalism investigation
you could talk about yeah innocent man
who was yet to be charged with a crime
has had his Liberty deprive to them and
I think that would be a far more
interesting angle than talking about me
being the most dangerous man that walks
out of the Congress yeah because he owns
a car and smokes cigars and this
question about schools which gives off
remember misogynistic energy it's the
Bugatti and the cigar which gives us
which gives off the funny speak
misogynistic energy very worried about
your influence Boys in primary school or
you know boys as young as 11 are quoting
you at school attacking girls
refusing to respect female teachers
would you like to say anything about
that I'd like to say a lot first things
first as I've repeatedly said and the
only reason I keep repeating it because
I'm sure this
yeah down to 12 minutes
male or female of any age and a lot of
women listen to me as well 40 of people
listen to me are actually female
secondly I do understand with my massive
influence and I am now the one the most
influential people on the planet that I
do have to be slightly more careful with
things I say I'm not going to disagree
with that the idea that I said something
five years ago on a video that got 300
views so what do you mean being slightly
more careful I'll give you an example
some of the jokes I made four or five
years ago on the YouTube channel that
got 300 views I would no longer make
like
the only Fan's joke the one you
mentioned repeat she said my man's car
is my car and then she said she did only
fans and I said what you saw on the fan
she said my tits and I said well those
are your man's tits as a joke hahaha
everybody laughed the point the fact
that I could do that on a podcast five
years ago it only got 300 views now I
understand I'm the most influential man
on the face of the planet I would be
more careful with certain things I say
that doesn't mean the things I
originally said were genuinely out to
harm people do you really believe you're
the most influential man on the face of
the planet on those Google personal
planets do you believe you're the most
influential man on the face of the
planet and there was Google Now on the
planet
yes that's why the BBC is in his house
they're not in Julian assange's house
they're not in Kim Kardashian's house
they're in my house they're not at my
brother's house not my dad's house
they're at Andrew's house because he's
most influential man on planet
today he is he may not be tomorrow but
today is
I think we're done oh
wait wait how did that end let me go
back
that was awkward do you really believe
you're the most influential man on the
face of the planet I know it's Google
person on the planet do you believe
you're the most influential man on the
face of the planet I'm always Googled me
on the planet whoo
the thing was on I think it was on guys
that's it
I think we're done thanks Lucy
is enjoyable nice to meet you
so angry
she's so awesome
she can't even look him in the eye look
how upset she is
oh my God this is so cool don't damage
anything
look at how she's being so emotional
oh my God she's moving
he says nice to meet you again
Lucy refuses to shake his hand wow wow
wow wow what happened until innocent
until proven guilty let me see if I can
get rid of this and that was a problem
I'm trying to as he stop scream
let's see if I can make me big oh there
we go all right oh this is a bit close
let's move it back a bit
okay
oh what happened until innocent until
proven guilty
that is not very nice this that's just
very this isn't very nice I feel like if
it was a man he would have probably had
a bit more manners to be honest I think
Lucy was being a bit emotional at the
end but anybody any anybody anyway thank
you guys so much for tuning in
um leave your comments in the comment
section I'm gonna be replying to all of
you
um also if you enjoyed this please don't
forget to hit the like button and also
subscribe we have so much more content
coming I actually just did an interview
with Myron Gaines from fresh and fit so
that's going to be going live really
soon so make sure you subscribe I have
an interview with Greg o Gallagher going
live very soon we have some crypto
content coming
um I did an interview with Brad Nuna bit
voices so many amazing podcasts coming
guys please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe and I will see you
all I think probably next week when my
next video comes out all right have a
great day